[Music]
i promise you you'll always sound better
than me so you sound fine no it's just
that matt qua subject has some
difficulty incorporating the mic into
the ready to hand uh i see yeah for him
it remains this alienated object though
we are holding out hope that it becomes
part of his uh body schema and stays by
his mouth
han lekheit except with the mouth what
is that
moonlit height
well uh i'm i'm actually in a closet so
i'm not able to move too much anyway
all right why don't i run the intro
which is
not something that we run hello hello
are we on okay we're on if you don't
know what's going on here this is the
pillpot coming at you from canada's
downtown toronto your
weekly critical theory and philosophy
podcast
today is matt and i
but not only matt and i we're taking a
break from your regularly scheduled
phenomenology to discuss
a youtube channel a book
and the voice behind them
that voice is of course that of
the artist formerly known as cuck
philosophy
now known as jonas chaka
how's the pronunciation on that am i am
i that's pretty good yeah it's uh
yawnless chica giannis okay here to talk
about
marx and nietzsche so welcome here jonas
thank you thank you for having me it's
great to be here do you have any
clarification on the state of the name
cuck cck what do you go by what's off
limits um i pretty much uh accept
whatever name people call me um
so usually these days people say either
cck or they just say jonas cheika um
people are sort of getting used to just
calling the name or calling the channel
cck philosophy
which doesn't stand for anything but
well the struggle will be real because
cuck philosophy has become
a household name in some households so
we're definitely gonna have to pivot
here yeah
yeah it was kind of like a
really drastic decision
um
to change my channel name at that point
uh but i just felt like
if i'm gonna release a book and uh
and i'll have family members looking at
it i don't really want them to see
cuck
well i should say your channel has
actually been my go-to place for
a lot of the books i purchased actually
in the last three years since your
favorite books 2018 2019 and 2020 a
healthy number of them made their way to
myself myself including um nancy loves
march nietzsche and modernity uh i
really appreciated that one suggestion
yeah you've read it
yeah it's excellent um i mean actually
she's contributing to a collection on
nietzsche uh that i'm editing because i
enjoyed the book so much so
yeah i just kind of um
i think i just found it on amazon like
and i hadn't heard of the book or or her
before and yeah it was extremely useful
like while writing my own book because
she even though she you know her
ultimate conclusion is that they're
incompatible
um she just lays out so many
like similarities and and
uh yeah overlaps between the two so yeah
it was a pretty useful book absolutely
uh so actually i just had a couple
questions uh to kind of get us started
uh and i guess the number one uh
question i had is i started watching you
back in 2018 when i was living in mexico
and i'm not gonna forget the moment uh
it's when i was on a treadmill and i was
really bored because you know that's the
way it is and i was like gotta watch
something entertaining and i watched
your video on stephen hicks of all
things uh uh-huh uh you know taking down
his book analyzing his account of
postmodernity and i thought geez this is
really refreshing we need more people to
do that
so actually you inspired me in part to
start doing these kinds of takedowns of
different conservative thinkers that i
do including hicks but can you tell me a
little bit about what inspired you to
start this channel uh was it just
reading a lot of shitty conservative
takes on left-wing or major philosophers
or was there some other motivation some
dark secret you're hiding from your
audience um
actually
the
the sort of idea of taking down
conservative takes or whatever like that
came pretty late
um
the original idea was
to make more like the type of videos
like the marxist analysis of shrek
um
like what i was actually inspired at
first is like the idea of
applying serious theory to like really
goofy pieces of like pop culture
um remember in particular
like
somehow i had found this paper
that was a marxist analysis of the movie
uh mean girls
and
and that seemed to me like something i i
want to do so it was sort of just like
originally almost like a joke
but also a joke that tries to
be accurate on the theory
um
and then like at the time i was like
starting to read a lot of the like
french post-structuralists
um
and and also that was the time when like
jordan peterson was at his most popular
and
you know just from my like beginners
uh like level of understanding i could
see just how much peterson misrepresents
um these thinkers like foucault and
dereda
and
you know i just saw more and more of of
of that online and and uh
i don't know i just felt like a strong
urge to correct people so i i released
the video like on jordan peterson and
postmodernism uh and that was actually
the first video of mine that got like
really popular i bet
well i'm gonna wager to guess that a
large portion of our listener base knows
you are as one of the most popular
youtube channels that does philosophy in
video essay form
and i mean i guess that would shift
depending on how broad your definition
of philosophy is
but it was sometimes sometime around
here
when i started watching you that it was
like
philosophy tube
school of life
and then lectures that constituted
youtube philosophy and i think it's i
think it's expanded since then quite a
bit i've considered making like a video
about the school of life
um because i'm not a huge fan as you can
guess
yeah big joel did one recently i started
following you when you had like 20 000
subs and i thought for the first time oh
[ __ ] there's an internet audience for
philosophy
with its difficulty including its
questions and of course we're all in
this game you cannot present philosophy
without grossly oversimplifying some
aspect of it that's just part of the
medium if you want it to be useful
because ultimately the purpose is that
you can engage someone
with something difficult but i think
when i first watched your channel if you
wanted to watch anybody video on youtube
there was like one 8-bit philosophy
thing that was pretty terrible
or some lectures that are over an hour
long or your video which is 10 minutes
here's the outline of the theorist and
10 minutes here's the application so
yours was the first time that i felt
there was a balance between the
difficulty and the application
you made me believe in internet
philosophy jonas i don't know if that's
for the better or for the worse
but
you bear some of the responsibility for
us all sitting here well yeah it said
something to be proud about um but yeah
it just kind of shows uh
just how much people are actually
interested in philosophy because
like
there's been so many like um
people like like new atheists or like
pop scientists claiming that you know
philosophy is useless or dead or that it
doesn't matter anymore
um but it's obvious that people you know
still want philosophy or at least a
substitute
um and
like yeah didn't you hear richard
dawkins you know the reason he says
philosophy is dead is because he loves
truth so much you know he truths so hard
that he just can't help but say these
things right
yeah
yeah i i loved uh
have you seen that richard dawkins tweet
where he was like how can there be such
a thing as continental philosophy how
can philosophy be particular to a
particular continent asking the deep
questions that's we
got to get to the bottom of this one
guys yeah this was also a guy who was
like kafka how do people turn into bugs
don't like it really weird zero stars
for the metamorphosis right i'm sorry to
say it's absolute rubbish it's
impossible
anyway jonas i'm interested to know now
that you've written a book so you're
you're now a multimedia artist
what is the strength of the video essay
medium and and what with your youtube
channel humming along what makes you
decide one day
you know i cannot do another video essay
until this book gets written how did
that become the the next project for you
and just as an addendum i was actually
worried that your channel had gone
you know into the ether because i was
like man it's been a long time since
he's actually published anything i
wonder if he's just moved on with his
life and then all of a sudden you were
everywhere you know talking about the
book releasing videos doing the q a i
was like oh so he was just rating this
260 page opus for our benefits sounds
like it was time well spent
yeah um
well like it definitely wasn't like
uh pre-planned
it was actually just i'd like
i i had some like thoughts about writing
a book before but what really started it
was that
uh
someone
who like
personally knew the publisher
just emailed me and said
i you know if you're interested in
writing a book i could get you in touch
with repeater books
um and i said you know i'll think about
it maybe
and
they got me in touch and actually a year
passed before i
i suddenly had the idea of like
writing a book on nietzsche
um
and
and yeah so it was actually like the
offer came to me first and then i just
like spent a lot of time wondering
what i could possibly write about
um
and nietzsche seemed like a natural like
choice
uh first of all because he's like a very
controversial thinker and uh
you know
everyone knows him but everyone has
different ideas about about him
um and also you know
like
he has influenced a lot of the
post-structuralist
stuff that i've talked about in my
youtube channel
so it seemed like a natural choice
and
my initial idea was to write
uh just the kind of left-wing
perspective reading of nietzsche
and i was going to just
uh
talk about like leftists and socialists
who've been inspired by nietzsche and
have written about it him and then as
i've researched
i ended up like finding
more and more interesting points of
similarity specifically with marx
so while i was working on the book
um
mark sort of uh became like the second
half of the book yeah and and and again
you know marx is also like someone
everyone knows
uh but is very very often misrepresented
so
it just seemed like a a good topic to
write a book about
yeah and i have to say uh i'm super
jealous of this title i'll get into like
what the book's about because your
questions about it but how to
philosophize with a hammer and sickle
nietzsche marks the 21st century i saw
that and i was like god damn you know
it's like kind of the beach boys looking
up at the beatles and thinking like [ __ ]
i'm never gonna come up with a title as
good as that
thank you thank you i'm glad to hear
that because actually like
towards the end of writing the book i i
was considering changing the title
uh but uh my publisher encouraged me not
to so
i'm glad i made the right decision
i don't i don't think no matter how many
possible worlds you have that there's a
better name than that yeah yeah i'm
pretty happy with it yeah
so as one more
initial question we've had
a lot of books
on both nietzsche
and marx
so what was it that made you think we
need one more book on these guys
and the thrust of the question is really
who's the audience who should pick this
thing up
um
my main goal was kind of similar to what
i try to do with my videos
which is to keep it like
accessible to non-experts
while trying not to dumb it down right
yeah so
like
i wasn't like
writing like necessarily with other
academics in mind
i i thought a lot about like
uh the lay people who will probably read
it and so i've tried to keep it
accessible
and so that naturally led to like
um criticizing some very popular
misrepresentations of marx in particular
but nietzsche also
and at the same time i've tried to like
keep it interesting enough
that people who already ha already are
familiar with mark sinicha
would you know still find it interesting
to read because maybe my interpretation
isn't like the most standard one
uh
so i've honestly i've kind of just tried
to
uh write for everyone i i guess it's
kind of like uh this book zarathustra
it's a book for everyone and no one
yeah our book for free spirits is uh
kind of what i was thinking of when i
was reading this right because it's
definitely a book that challenges a lot
of our conceptions well just before we
dive into the kind of substance of this
and some of your other work
i noticed uh in the book you have a long
section about academic philosophy uh
including some pretty funny pot shots
that analytic philosophers in particular
but you describe academic philosophy as
kind of a necessary enterprise and it
produces useful things in some cases
people like william van norman quine
appears at various points in the book
but you say you know the problem with
academic philosophy is oftentimes it's
very dry
extremely narrowly focused uh and it
doesn't like to think about these kind
of big pictures i'm just putting it
really simply issues yeah yeah and
develop as you call it sometimes total
critiques of society including things
like capital and its global impact
so can you tell us a little bit about
that like what's wrong in your opinion
with
academic philosophy the kind of
program that sits there and says if you
want a career in this discipline your
job is to go
read shelling and then write an essay or
a thesis on one of his books and try to
carve out your narrow niche in the
scholarship there
yeah so like
if you look at
precisely marx and nietzsche
they were both themselves you know very
critical of of academia and and they
weren't really academic thinkers you
know nietzsche uh left university at an
early age um you know marx wrote a phd
but then you know most of his career was
not in academia
and
it was because
they didn't write just
with other for other academics that they
were able to reach such an influence
right and i think
uh one of the problems is that
you know if you want to have a good
academic career
you have to write four other academics
basically
and that's one problem and another
problem
which is kind of you know
i guess the problem of of knowledge
today in general is that it encourages
increasing and like increasing
specialization
to the point where
you know every uh particular person is
focusing on such a
small you know part of a particular
sub-topic
um
that you know as you mentioned it's kind
of difficult to see the big picture
um
and and you know
it's kind of it's kind of this like
general problem of um of knowledge we
have where you know baudrillard said
that we have more and more information
but less and less meaning
and uh
and you know everyone has to be such a
specialist
that it can be hard to see how all of
these different specialties relate to
each other and form something coherent
i guess those would be like my main
criticisms and obviously it's not to say
that
academia is useless or that it produces
nothing
nothing worthwhile um but
i think it's a problem that
you know especially in the past few
decades um
academia like especially academic
philosophy has been kind of like a
self-enclosed bubble where not much
comes out to influence you know the
general culture
um and i think that's something that
should be you know struggle against
yeah i remember uh when i was in grad
school i was told if you publish a paper
in a pretty good journal
that a hundred people read and two
comment on it you're doing a pretty good
job uh yeah this is when i was like 23
24 whenever i was starting my phd
forever ago it seems and a part of me
was like boy that's a pretty big
pressure it's got to be a good article
but i also thought like man that's a
pretty narrow aspiration in life so
two people will give enough of a [ __ ]
about what i work on to comment on it
and that's going to be a milestone
you know yeah right and compared like
you know like compared with uh someone
like hegel who was like a celebrity like
people would literally pay for tickets
to see lectures by hagel
and things have changed so much
and i and i think it's a shame that you
know
there's there's this sentiment in in in
in the general culture that you know
philosophy isn't significant anymore and
i think uh
you know to fight that we have to kind
of try to break out of the academic
bubble and
and and also to try to
you know
make our philosophy be significant for
non-academic matters
right because that's what marx and
nietzsche tried to do they
they they learned from academia and then
they try to apply it you know outside of
academia to the most significant
parts of human life
so so you're a pretty popular figure in
the internet kind of discourse of of
philosophy do you invest much time in it
are you happy with where it's at do you
think it can be improved what can be
improved
i'm interested in your uh your scope of
the landscape um just regarding like
internet philosophy generally yeah
us on twitter
well
twitter is kind of a problem you know no
no no no no no sorry okay twitter was
totally a joke not twitter per se i just
mean the fact that i think anyway
this conversation would have not taken
place
four years ago
there are youtubers doing some kind of
primary source philosophy there are
podcasts
uh not just ours but like asset verizon
doing actual readings twitter itself is
a joke those are wrong twitter is where
the greatest minds of our generation
meet to exchange the deepest thoughts
and the most profound media i mean
besides that though
yeah lately yeah
well
i don't know it's kind of hard to get an
overview i mean like i'm glad that
there's been
um
such a proliferation of internet
philosophy i think that's something that
should be welcomed um
obviously sometimes the medium itself
can be a problem
you know especially on twitter i think
uh
one problem with the
internet philosophy is that
it uh often encourages like very
i don't know like division into groups
where where every single question has to
be
understood as like a conflict between
two internet subcultures
um
but uh
but i don't know if that's just like a
part of
the internet as a medium
um
no i think that's very true i mean um
i've written for a number of different
magazines and i published one
article that was like
reasonably well received about like the
idw criticizing them and i just got like
loads of requests including from the
same publisher being like more stuff on
the idw more stuff on the idw and my
response is like well first off they've
already said kind of what i wanted to
about this and second off like
there's really not much to say i mean
their
criticisms and comments are pretty
brittle you point that out and that's
more or less what you can do uh if you
don't want to like diagnose them
culturally
uh yeah but there really was this kind
of pressure you know more of the same
more
us versus them kind of mentality have
you experienced something similar
well
people do kind of expect you to yeah
kind of like
uh
stay within a certain narrow circle of
what you're exploring so for example
uh you know i used to do videos mostly
on post-modernism right and then when i
became i sort of became more explicitly
marxist
um there were a lot of really angry
people like you know
uh
like oh i sub to your channel because
you were giving these uh you know good
explanations of post-modernism and now
you're doing this like political
radicalism and i want no part of it
there is that
um
yeah but like
but at the same time there is a kind of
you know freedom to it that you wouldn't
get in academia because it's
in the you know in the end it is me who
decides what i'm going to do a video
about
um
and
and the people who sort of you the
people who support me on patreon at
least
are pretty happy to endorse uh you know
whatever i want to talk about so long as
it's interesting enough
yeah the crowdfunded model makes so much
more content possible than would be
otherwise for sure
absolutely so there's a quote in your
book just to push back on that a little
bit um
where you say uh will make william
willard uh the enemy for today the
american philosopher willard van
ormenkwein who is nevertheless an
undoubtedly worthwhile philosopher uh
and i agree and everyone should read two
dogmas of empiricism uh encapsulated the
academic will to truth when he said and
this is a quote from him the student who
majors in philosophy primarily for
spiritual comfort is misguided and
probably not a very good student anyway
since intellectual curiosity is not what
moves him
and you respond by saying behind kwine's
denigration of quote spiritual comfort
which despite his peculiar wording is a
reasonable thing to look for in
philosophy hides the fact that what quan
calls the good student also finds a form
of comfort
a spiritual comfort in academic
philosophy the comfort of satisfying the
will to truth writing from the
perspective of no one erasing oneself in
the text of becoming a non-individual in
one's research right and i think that's
a great critique of twine but isn't
there a danger in looking to
let's just call it internet philosophy
for a kind of spiritual comfort uh
precisely because the kind of
intellectual standards quine is putting
forward can get watered down a little
bit you know we were taking shots at
school of life and i agree with that
early on but i mean one of the things
that they put themselves forward as is
as a kind of medium for comfort
ideas in their most digestible form and
i see a lot of that on the internet so
is this a danger you think
yeah well
it kind of depends on
what kind of comfort we're talking about
because
i do think that
philosophy should be related
to you know human affects and and uh you
know the sort of let's say spiritual
needs of human beings right um and
the thing about the school of life is
it's not particularly good at even
delivering that
like
you know with the school of life i don't
think the problem is that they're too
focused on like
just giving you something comfortable
and that's it
i think
i don't think they're even able to
deliver that because
the kind of content they provide is
something that you've heard a hundred
times before
and you know
it might give someone like
a philosopher's name to throw out to
sound clever but i don't think it's
actually like
you know
a means by which to like
struggle with your emotions or struggle
spiritually
and
and the people who do provide a certain
kind of spiritual comfort like maybe
nietzsche you know are are thinkers that
you have to kind of struggle through
um
yeah i don't know if that answers your
question i think that's so on point
because i mean i got this beef with
philosophers quote unquote who say
here's why you just should be fine
compared to those who say
you don't feel fine and here's
part of the reason why
or why not i was just gonna say this is
the problem i have with the channel is
that
and other things like it it gives you
kind of the safest most bourgeois most
coffee table interpretation of what are
sometimes really dangerous radical
provocative thinkers uh and says you
know here's consolation when really what
was
interesting about people like
kierkegaard or mark sunicha uh is
precisely that they demanded you pay
more attention uh to the problems in
your life you don't try to
opiate them away uh but rather say jesus
you know life is full of suffering and
[ __ ] i really have to think carefully
about how i'm gonna respond to that yeah
like my main problem with
quine was this idea that
in philosophy you have to basically
become a non-individual
where your personal concerns
you know don't matter and you have to
kind of become this
pure you know affectless subject
and i think that
you know
as i as i said in the book that you know
even the most
analytic philosophers
are still driven by something personal
are still driven by some kind of affect
in their philosophical endeavors um
uh and and i i think that uh
yeah pointing that out is important
is it al and de botton's book called the
constellation of philosophy
is it i'm not sure
he's about he's all about consoling you
know
oh yeah
he does have a very soothing voice
though you know what i mean
[Laughter]
a friend of mine actually read that book
um
and uh you know
gave a kind of uh overview of it for me
but uh you know one thing in particular
he mentioned was
uh
you know just the very idea
of
you know reducing nietzsche to like a
figure of consolation
um is kind of a problem because
you know
maybe it ends in consolation but but at
least at first nietzsche should sort of
make you uncomfortable a little bit i i
i'd have to like look back at the notes
that he wrote for me but
it kind of goes back to that general
thing that school of life does
where
it takes these you know like big
thinkers
and reduces them to these like
platitudes right like everything has a
purpose or
yeah i don't know we want we want the
popularization of philosophy in one
sense but not necessarily pop philosophy
in this sense yeah so speaking of the
niches because there are
multiple nietzsche's and you've made
your case for one
but of course we can't forget there's
the sexist nietzsche
the proto-fascist nietzsche
and lately we've seen this in current
not just of school and life but also our
daddy
our toronto daddy jordan b peterson he's
got this self-help nietzsche that's
tailored for
the the young males with the star wars
moral architecture
um so i was wondering what does your
nietzsche correct in this amalgam
because it's going to be contentious of
course nietzsche is not a socialist
well you say that
you wouldn't read on its face
immediately that he's a socialist yeah
um yeah i agree i don't think he's a
socialist system so what are you trying
to mix in here to i guess fix or defend
or challenge those other interpretations
uh that's a big question so
uh
if you if you want a simpler version of
the question we could go back to um
when you said uh
you should struggle through something
what is the thing you think we should
struggle through there
with socialist nietzsche so
there's kind of you know
two aspects to it which first of all
concerns
not trivializing marx and then not
trivializing nietzsche
so
um
and
and what shouldn't be trivialized about
both of them is the fact that they
wanted a fundamentally
transformed world a fundamentally
different form of human life
and what's happened with both of them
is
marx has been kind of used
not as that kind of figure but as
someone who just wants to kind of
fix certain you know surface problems
in our current world or you know wants
to make certain reforms
and and then you know nietzsche has also
been trivialized in that sense where you
know
his uh his desire to transform the world
is you know say reduced to just like
clean your an academic literary practice
or something like that
um
and
you know
and also i don't claim to
you know
simply represent directly what nietzsche
believed because obviously he wasn't a
socialist um
it was more so
you know taking this nietzschean drive
to transform the world
um and looking at how
that might be used by a socialist and
and and how that might be applied to our
current world
uh you know the world of global capital
and um how we could use you know
nietzsche's
existential goals
and realize them in marx's material
goals and um
um
yeah and also like
nietzsche kind of has this idea that
the sense of a given entity is not
given in itself but is only produced by
another entity sort of taking possession
of it
and that's obviously very true with
readings of nietzsche themselves and i
think every reading of nietzsche is kind
of like an example of one will to power
taking over another one that is
nietzsche's works
and kind of producing something new uh
from it
and this book is is itself a case of
that and um
and because of that i think in chapter
three i talk about
you know both the ways that nazis have
used nietzsche
but then also the ways that uh
communists and socialists have used
nietzsche
um to sort of you know illustrate that
point
and and one of my interests is precisely
you know the form that nietzsche took
when being utilized by radical thinkers
i should say yeah i think you're very
successful at that uh and i think one of
the problems i have whenever i read
secondary needed literature on nietzsche
or marxa uh
submitting this collection on nietzsche
i've read a lot of that now is that
their personality kind of gets swallowed
up by the gigantic personality of the
antichrist right and what's really nice
about your book is that your personality
still shines through
if you want to put it in kind of neutral
terms
there is a sense where one will to power
is confronting another will
and
it creates something productive and
interesting from this dynamic but you
don't get subsumed uh by the kind of
literature that you're working on which
is quite an accomplishment um i had a
quick question though so
correct me if i'm wrong because this was
my interpretation of your book as much
of it as i've read so far because i
still again have 80 pages left uh and
again if you claim that you're an
objectivist and you know tell everyone
to clean their room at the end
and that was the secret lesson of this
whole text forgive me okay
um but
i was a bit surprised when reading it
because i thought that this was mostly
going to be a book on marx or marx
interpreting uh nietzsche through a
marxist lens but what i notice is that
nietzsche is really the primary
character
in the text you know the primary figure
that you deal with but what's
interesting about it is of course since
you argue for a kind of niching
socialism that is violence right in the
sense of doing violence to nietzsche's
text it's almost like you're trying to
push nietzsche towards marx uh so there
is a kind of dynamic tension between the
two where marx is almost the primary
figure uh just kind of
out there and nietzsche has to kind of
be pushed towards him would you say that
that's an interesting or correct
characterization of the book or would
you look at it a different way
i i think that's fair
um
because
you know again one of the points i make
early on in the book is that
um
any interpretation of a significant
thinker has to be in some sense
selective
um and whether you're reading nietzsche
as like a postmodernist or a reactionary
or you know a radical you'll always be
selective towards certain parts of
nietzsche i mean there's there's
there's just no other option you have to
be selective and um and nietzsche
himself you know in in neke homo in his
uh last published book
he looked back at his own works
and was selective towards them himself
nietzsche's selection process is in eke
homo
why i write such good books
and why i am so yeah i have to be
selective but also you know proud and
and confident
uh
but yeah because
uh
to put it in kind of
different terms
um
i tried to write this book not as a
representation but as an event right
right because you know if you're trying
to just
purely represent
you know
without any impurities what what a
particular philosopher thought the best
you can come up with is just the perfect
you know copy of their own works
so like any interesting interpretation
must be
selective in in some sense and also push
a thinker
into something i hear that man and
what i wanted to make sure to do is
to make that explicit and conscious so
that people don't feel like
i'm kind of tricking them into accepting
a certain version of nietzsche but i
made clear from the beginning
that
like all philosophy this is a selective
work it is driven by
personal goals and affects i have
and it is a kind of personal endeavor
even though
you know
i i tried also as much as i can to let
marx and nietzsche speak for themselves
within that kind of selection
absolutely so this is kind of the heart
of the book so
we can take it in a few stages if you
want but
for those of us and i include myself in
that category who might be skeptical
that nietzsche has much in the way to
offer socialists
what
does he have to offer socialists like
why do we need nietzsche or at least
this very creative
radical interpretation of nietzsche uh
that you're giving in the book yeah i
wanted to just add our our longtime
listeners right might remember a
particular guest
who went so far as to suggest that we
shouldn't even read nietzsche because
the proto-fascist seed is in there and
if you read it it's gonna
get into your heart
and you know wrap its roots around it
and you're going to become a fascist
i'm only overstating a little bit which
is the sad part
yeah that was a spicy episode
i'll never forget that
just like you're wrong
who was it uh ronald boehner um
rodney he's actually a good friend of
mine we need for coffee every now and
then and he's contributing to the
collection but yeah he does not like
nietzsche uh at all
and we wrote a very good we didn't all
see eye to eye on this interpretation
if you want uh you might actually be
interested um he spoke his uh
dangerous minds uh nietzsche heidegger
and the return of the far right um
and actually he doesn't have the name
yeah he has a similar kind of background
to you where he says you know fascinated
by nietzsche early on really kind of
electrified by his thinking um but they
kind of turned against him uh later on
when he saw how he was influencing some
of these other people but yeah that
reminds me a bit of um um
an academic by the name of jeff waite
who wrote a book called nietzsche's
corpse i don't know if you've heard of
it i've heard of it
yeah
he kind of has this similar idea where
um
nietzsche for him is almost like this
infectious force that turns people who
otherwise might be communists into like
secret reactionaries well we do have to
get these reactionaries under control
like batai
toulouse
you know they're just they're going out
they're saying whatever they want out
there you know but
one thing that i have noticed
while writing this book is that
as
as marxism has been in my view in
various ways
distorted and weakened and trivialized
it is often precisely
those parts of him
that link him to nietzsche
that have been kind of removed from
marxism
so i'm thinking for example of uh the
critique of morality right uh to extend
the critique of of nationalism
uh
you know
nietzsche even critiques things like
wage labor and the state
um
in his own particular way
um and and i don't think that's you know
i don't think that's a coincidence i
think that there's something
there's a kind of radical spirit to
nietzsche
that again comes from his desire to
you know
negate the modern world for the sake of
something new
that he shares with marx and i think
that's something that should be upheld
in marx
so
i talk about stuff like that and then
also
when it comes to nietzsche's critiques
of socialism
what i notice is that
you know
funnily enough
a lot of the critiques nietzsche makes
about socialism
marx made himself yeah so for example i
should say i think that's the most
convincing part of the book uh where i
learned the most actually
yeah so for example in the 1844
manuscripts
uh marx criticized what he calls crude
communism
and uh the things he says about it is
for example that it is actually
uh disguised envy and greed that it
reduces uh it you know
minimizes the world of art and culture
um that it's that it is a kind of
leveling down right
all of the things precisely that
nietzsche
criticized in socialism um
and
you know we can also talk about you know
the socialist figures that nietzsche was
familiar with but the foremost
representative of socialism for
nietzsche was organ during
um
who was an anti-marxist and also an
anti-semite and marx and angles
themselves you know hated him
and kind of uh poked fun at him for
uh for still believing that he has like
discovered a universal and absolute uh
moral system
and uh
and you know
engels wrote
literally wrote a book called
anti-during
almost like you know antichrist
um
and
and excerpts uh of that book
um were then published as socialism
utopian and scientific and became
one of the most you know significant uh
popular texts of like classical marxism
so
yeah that's a pretty significant thing
that
nietzsche's criticisms of socialism are
you know worth listening to and should
be taken seriously
because in many ways they overlap with
marx's own and kind of
they might teach us how to
prevent our own understandings of
socialism from becoming something
uh something you know trivial or
or you know or weak
yeah absolutely and i should say again i
think that that's the most for me
interesting part of the book uh and i
will say uh to those of our listeners
who know my opinions on this you did
make me budge on that right i think i
did think to myself okay this is a valid
point and i do need to consider it uh
and i'll get back to you with what my
final thoughts are but let's come at it
from a different direction so we talked
a little bit about what nietzsche gives
to marx in your opinion right um so what
then does marx offer nietzsche uh and
i'm thinking here that there are any
number of marxist figures i think
probably frederick jameson has
engaged with him in the most deep and
interesting way and the political
unconscious who say you know nietzsche
has some insights
but he lacks a lot of
good stuff let's just put it that way
right
in particular of course from a marxist
perspective he lacks a sustained
critique of the capitalist political
economy
you can find gestures of criticism
towards you know bourgeois moralism and
as you point out routinely in the book
you know their comments about the kind
of decadent quality
to affluence concentrating the
capitalist class but there's nothing
comparable to capital uh so what would
marx then have to teach nietzsche if you
know they were taking turns you know
educating one another
yeah so
one of nietzsche's biggest strengths is
also
his biggest weakness
which is that
um
he was in a certain way
disconnected
from
from his society right because you know
at an early age he left university
he was a very solitary figure
um
he uh
yeah he lived the rest of his life of
his you know university
pension and
and
one thing that that allowed him to do
is
perform a kind of
total critique
of the society which he was looking at
almost as if you know from afar
um because
he he didn't have to be an academic he
didn't have to be a work he didn't have
to be a worker he didn't have to be you
know a businessman and that kind of
allowed him to be equally critical
of all of those aspects of our society
and that was one of his strengths but
at the same time because he lacked
grounding
in in you know in the particular social
formations
of modernity
he
he wasn't particularly good at
providing kind of
uh the material point of view the
materialist point of view um you know
the materials materialist ideas about
what would you know
transform this world
um
and
as i mentioned in the book
you know early on
when he still you know hadn't isolated
himself he made various critiques
of bourgeois society including its
economy
including wage labor
um and
and then you know he he began talking
about this stuff less and less the more
isolated he became
and that was kind of a missing piece
from his philosophy
and uh and you know obviously that's
something marx provides
in um in daybreak nietzsche actually you
know talks about
how dehumanizing wage labor is
and and he suggests as a solution that
you know all these wage workers should
simply engage in mass emigration
um and that would somehow you know solve
their condition
i think that shows that nietzsche
saw the problems
with the forms of production and just
social formations in general of
bourgeois society but at the same time
because he kind of lacked
grounding in it
he lacked material ideas about how to
change it um so that's the part i think
that that mar that marx
brings to the table
if we are going to take a cue from
social forms of morality
or tables of values then christianity
liberalism and socialism are all
moral systems that really just allow
losers to get ahead for
for nietzsche and nietzsche doesn't
really take any pains to separate them
one from another so
if we commit to your reading then how do
we reconcile the individual
with the collective
um
so there's
several aspects to that
and
one part of nietzsche's critique
is
asceticism
and you know he often critiqued uh
socialism as being ascetic
and that actually made a lot of sense
because there were a lot of
um socialist groups at the time who were
kind of you know influenced by religious
thought and believe that socialism
involves like being more ascetic uh
denying your needs uh denying your
individuality for the sake of the
collective good
and marx's vision was
completely anti-ascetic
um you know marx has this idea that
the
proliferation of your own desires is
actually a good thing
that that we should proliferate our
desires and needs because that is what
makes us richer as people
um and he you know
in a lot of places made clear
that
this is the kind of society that that uh
that he
wants is is not one where individuals
deny themselves
for the sake of the collective good
but where individuals realize themselves
precisely through
collective forms of life um
and
you know and and sort of
you know there's almost there's there's
an individualist aspect to marx where
you know
everything that somehow
uh
that blocks my development as an
individual should be destroyed
so
you know marx isn't so much a
uh a collectivist
uh you know in the sense of being
opposed to individualism
he's someone who wants to
transcend the very
you know strict distinction between
individual and collective
and there's even you know
parts in nietzsche where that almost
seems to be happening um for example the
first time
uh nietzsche ever uses the term wilt to
power he actually isn't talking about an
individual will to power but he is
talking about the will to power of
different peoples
so there is that strain in nietzsche
um
and then
an another you know
uh
part of marx that is kind of nietzschean
um is
this idea of of empowerment
that you know the proletariat isn't like
good because it is meek
uh you know it's not
the proletariat shouldn't strive to be
sort of
the weak person
who is therefore morally good but
the proletariat is precisely
both dehumanized but in a certain sense
empowered in bourgeois society and that
empowerment
should be you know pushed to its extreme
and then and then there is also
yeah for example uh one interesting
thing i noticed was
um
nietzsche
uses a french
word
to describe certain elements of the herd
which is kane i think it is
and marx
in a letter uses that precise word and
said the proletariat must not be
you know kane
uh but must
you know
be strong and autonomous
and powerful
basically and um
so there's that emphasis on empowerment
um there's the emphasis on
anti-asceticism the proliferation of
needs
um
there there's probably more maybe
that'll yeah we'll i'll remember that
that's a great answer i i can tell
you've written a book on this
yeah thank you it's very comprehensive
and i should say i think you're
absolutely right that people often
misunderstand marxism as advocating for
a kind of
deflationary socialism where we all move
back to
basically the world of avatar you know
from the james cameron you know we all
hold hands and we swim from a tree and
we decide to give up uh you know
technology for the sake of a kind of
more primitive uh or at least more
naturalistic existence and he was very
opposed to that as a kind of good model
thinker
and as with nietzsche as well this is a
completely imbecilic response that
nietzsche wanted to return to the old
world order nietzsche wants to go back
and rewind the clock and live in in
ancient sparta no mother no
though
i've never even thought that nietzsche
was responding to particular groups of
socialists that he was watching i've
that never even occurred to me before so
that's very interesting
i'll let you the book when i'm done uh i
should be finished by tomorrow phil so
when i see you
uh um go ahead for example um
yeah like
one important like interesting thing to
point out
is that
um
the socialists that nietzsche was most
familiar with were all anti-semites so
for example
you know obviously he was familiar with
wagner who early on was a kind of
revolutionary he was anti-semitic
wagner was arguably influenced by
prudhon
who was also anti-semitic and then as i
mentioned the foremost representative of
socialism for nietzsche was during who
was also anti-semitic
um
and you know nietzsche famously said a
lot of
you know he hated anti-semites so it's
it's almost likely that in his mind
uh socialism and anti-semitism was to
some extent you know equated
yeah and again i think that's
a very interesting part of the book
particularly the talk discussions about
during anish's parallel criticisms of
during socialism uh along with angles
which is also a good book i should say
but i had a kind of different criticism
or comment
the one thing i thought that your book
maybe could have done a bit more of and
i say this with love because i kind of
wanted this uh is you indicate that
you're not really going to be dealing
with the religious dimensions of
modernization secularization
the criticism of christianity there are
references to it in the book but it's
not foregrounded
and
i'm wondering why you did that you chose
to do that because for somebody like me
modernity has to be understood in terms
of liberalization the spread of
capitalism and also secularization
and also because nietzsche
tied a lot of his criticisms of
egalitarian movements to a critique of
christianity uh both its metaphysics and
its morality uh he had this kind of
famous statement uh where he said
socialism is the residue of christianity
and rousseau in a de-christianized world
which is right a fascinating you know
kind of explanation
and i've kind of used this to myself to
criticize people like jordan peterson to
say look you know if you're really
looking for contemporary christians uh a
lot of them might look a lot like
the woke people uh out there advocating
for more equality more inclusion uh
more leveling
of
domineering social hierarchies
so this kind of take uh
is wrong right so how would you respond
to something like that and what do you
think
nietzsche
what how do you think we could extend
your book to an analysis of religion
so
the reason i didn't write a lot about
religion
um
because obviously both nietzsche and
marx
criticized religion and christianity in
particular
um part of it was just because
in our
culture in the past one or two decades
critiques of religion have been
you know done by these
self-congratulatory new atheists right
right
whose critiques of religion are like you
know only skin deep and don't actually
touch
you know the the fundamentals of our
society
and
i didn't want to give in to that kind of
uh self-congratulatory new atheism
but um i completely can empathize with
that by the way yeah i think that's
say no more i think that's a good
explanation you know
but also
but also because actually focusing on
you know focusing on religion is
important but it can also be misleading
in that it can sometimes
lead people to miss
you know
the kind of the the essence of the
critique so for example
nietzsche of course criticized
christianity but at the same time he
said that
certain secular thinkers in our age
are
not christian or at least you know not
explicitly christian
but they end up reproducing
the negative forms of christianity
right that they end up reproducing
the you know the slave morality of
christianity or the will to truth
and that you know
it's it's that point that can be missed
if you focus too much on religion
because
you know religion is kind of a social
phenomenon
and
being a social phenomenon
it can be in various forms reproduced
in secular form so
i wanted to
you know
there's a short section in the book
where i kind of talk about why
i don't
i mention why i don't talk that much
about religion in the book
um
and and and that is because
um i don't want to i don't want people
to kind of focus on the wrong thing
because
i think that in nietzsche's view
christianity at least in its explicit
form
could be eradicated
and yet its negative social effects
could still persist in society
yeah absolutely and i think that you
very right at least point out that
what's innovative about his commentary
is he doesn't just launch
we could call logical or epistemological
critiques of christian metaphysics
because he's aware of the fact that most
people don't believe in god because
they sat down and you know read saint
ansel's ontological proof of god's
existence right it's there's a social
function so you need to get at that and
understand it historically uh which i
think is really important to stress
right
and and speaking of historically i'm
gonna throw you just the broadest
question and you're gonna have to figure
out how to how to whittle it down i know
you have your your fourth chapters on
uh historical philosophy and
philosophical history and we've just
been name-dropping as we're prone to do
schopenhauer hegel marx nietzsche
post-modernism
and i was wondering how
specifically i would i would call their
forms of history different but they're
both
against a certain other kind of
historicism if you have nietzsche's kind
of an ecstatic existentialist
historicist versus marx who's a
materialist historicist
how do you uh how do you compare their
their views of history and maybe fit it
into
the rest of the stuff that we've been uh
yammering on about
could you ask a bigger question
well that's why i said he's gonna have
to wheel it down
i'm interested in the history question
one thing i think that's particularly
worth mentioning is that uh
marx is often interpreted and and
often is you know a lot of marxists read
marx as a teleol teleological thinker
where
and also a determinist thinker where
through a you know there's a a
particular progression
to history that you have to pass through
and that it inevitably leads towards a
certain goal
and
nietzsche is is well known as a critic
of teleological history nietzsche
emphasizes the contingent
you know ruptures
uh through the arbitrary aspects of
history
uh but marx also actually criticizes
teleology
um
he there's one i think in the german
ideology he says that this idea that
history moves towards a telos
is only a kind of uh
idea that is only produced after the
fact and kind of artificially applied to
past history it's not something that uh
that exists as as an inherent part of
history itself
and and marx uh
you know emphasize that that it is
particular individuals and the social
formations that they create that moves
history forward it's not anything like
spirit
and there's no kind of
de-individualized form of historical
progression
and he even
he congratulated darwin
for
in um i think he said uh that darwin
destroyed
teleology in the in the biological
sciences and and he praised him for that
no absolutely and
marx is well known for his marks
nietzsche is well known for his
genealogical analysis of history uh and
marx is well known for his dialectical
or historically dialectical account of
history
i don't want to get too much in the
weeds here but can you tell us a little
bit about what differentiates these two
ways of analyzing history
philosophically and what brings them
together since you spent a lot of time
kind of mincing this difficult
theoretical question in your book and i
think it is important for us to
understand some of these theoretical
subtleties
yeah that's a that's a great question
and i'm wondering if you can also
differentiate for us the
particular misconception of history as a
series of particular events towards a
given end compared to
what i see as their common trait which
is
between the two having history as the
appearance
and disappearance of values
so
one thing that uh that
brings them together actually i could
tie this back
to what you mentioned about marxism not
being a kind of return to nature
you know a return to primitive communism
i think there's a kind of similar
structure
to nietzsche and marx
where just as it's important to
emphasize that marx doesn't want to
return to primitive communism
nietzsche doesn't actually want to
return to master morality
because
you know this is a common misconception
that you know
he wants to return to master morality
where in fact
uh master morality
you know even though it was affirmative
it was still
kind of like
dumb in a sense it was almost like an
animal kind of existence and and you
think about just stomping around you
know near troy being like i'm the
biggest and the baddest and i'm going to
kill you all right no it's like
hector get your ass out here exactly
the you know it's like slave morality
uh as much as nietzsche critiques it it
actually sort of deepens human life
makes it more interesting it makes
individuals more interesting
and he says that uh great human beings
actually have a mix of slave morality
and master morality so
the kind of historical the
the the part of their historical
philosophy that i'm i'm pointing to here
is
is a dialectical term that they both
used
which is self style bung which is kind
of like self sublation
um
and nietzsche is often read as an
anti-dialectical thinker but there is at
least this dialectical aspect to the way
he views history
and that is that uh
you know that certain historical
formations end in a kind of negation of
the negation where
you know slave morality negates mass uh
master morality but then that that
negation the negation of slave morality
in turn
isn't a mere reversal
but a kind of
sublation of the two
so what nietzsche i think is pointing to
in the ubermensch
is a kind of
mix that takes both the positive from
master morality and the positive from
slave morality
just as for marx
you know
in a certain sense
uh
communism
returns to primitive communism in the
sense of common property
but it is it does like
um a completely
you know advanced stage because it
contains within itself the entire
history of bourgeois society
and utilizes the forces of production
that bourgeois society has produced
um so there's that broad yeah that's the
broad historical uh
similarity that these two thinkers have
um i think it's important to emphasize
that the end goal is not just a simple
reversal
um and and that's a simplification that
i think has done a lot of harm that's so
true and it's done the harm to both of
them yeah and this is the kind of
dumb oversimplification
that is not
that you don't just find this in
internet philosophy but you also find
this in
accepted academic readings of nietzsche
exactly specifically in political
philosophy
like look
if you think that you've suddenly
discovered an interpretation that ends
with you being really smart and with
nietzsche and marx being totally
ignorant of the ongoing dialectic of
values yeah
and not even dialectic but the accident
of values from history then sorry
the problem is probably with your
interpretation
but
you're doing the good
sort of violence
in my opinion you're doing the good sort
of violence to the text which is to say
i don't care what you thought you meant
here is the correct
hermeneutic
and this is the kind of reading that i
find respected and i should say uh my
favorite video of yours uh is actually a
fairly recent one of yours uh i did
enjoy the doom one by the way because
killing margaret thatcher as a demon
does sound fun uh but it's actually uh
about kentaromiro's uh berserk
which is a favorite uh anime of mine uh
and it
he wrote characters really successfully
that seemed to embody this nietzschean
ethos in the sense of being kind of
achilles-like you know strong and
powerful and life-affirming but they did
have the kind of soul of a christ-like
figure in the sense that they were
reflective
deep asked themselves whether they were
doing the right thing uh they weren't
just wore like kind of dummies to use
your terminology and shout out to our
our bible people out there but nietzsche
thought it was an affront to put the new
testament of the bible next to the old
testament of the bible because the new
testament is a bunch of [ __ ]
whereas the old testament is
king david who is
on one hand the warrior
and then on the other hand the poet
yeah
because like
if you like look
just you know
at first glance if you look at guts you
know the main character yeah it's kind
of uh he's like achilles on steroids
right he's got the [ __ ] yeah
that like he unites like they're nothing
yeah like at first he it might seem like
the most stereotypical action hero
possible like this huge muscular guy
with a huge sword and he slays demons
and enjoys it and he loves being covered
in blood and i do enjoy it but they're
not gonna lie yeah it's pretty cool yeah
of course but then like what really
makes this character special is when you
go deeper into the story
and you find underneath it all
that he has like trauma
and and and psychological needs and and
ambitions and yeah so it's that kind of
uh
precisely i i never actually thought of
this uh thought of it this way but he's
kind of like a combination of
master and slave morality where
he's kind of like
affirmative but without being
you know dumbed down to a kind of like
muscle-bound freak you know so is
griffith for that matter uh even though
i hate him yeah which reminds me any of
our listeners if you like berserk uh
1990s tv show is all on youtube now so
dm me if you're interested always talk
about it uh but i i had okay just to
kind of move in the direction of
wrapping up uh one of the key sections
of your book uh is a probably called a
nietzschean socialism
which i imagine
i think at least is that's going to give
you the most flack can you give us a
quick introduction to what a nietzsche
and socialism would look like so we've
done a criticism we've analyzed some of
their criticisms their methods their
historical analyses
what's the cash payoff to use a vulgar
term from this in terms of niching
socialism yeah and and have you gotten
any [ __ ] for it yet or is that right
good question
um
actually not uh
not that much i mean
i saw in goodreads there were two people
who gave me one star that's probably
have something to do with that uh
and uh
and there's been like you know a couple
people who have kind of you know scoffed
at this idea that you're going to use
nietzsche for socialism
but no extended critique which obviously
i welcome i'd be interested to hear more
extended critiques
um we'll get jordan peterson on the line
yeah yeah
yeah hopefully you can he'll uh read my
book
um
but so
you know there's parts of nietzsche and
socialism i've already touched on which
is that it's a form of empowerment and
the proliferation of needs
the proliferation of art and culture
rather than you know denying yourself
for the sake of the collective good
um it's also as we've mentioned um a
self-sublation rather than a mere
reversal
that it's it's not just primitive
communism and and also
uh another way to look at this is that
uh
uh
you know in in bourgeois society you
have this struggle between the worker
and the capitalist and often uh
the way that marxism is understood as is
as a reversal of those two terms
where
you know the worker becomes the absolute
side of society rather than the
capitalist but again it's actually a
sublation
where for marx
the worker as such doesn't really exist
in socialism you just have human beings
who who produce but they're not wage
laborers they're not there to you know
feed the mechanisms of capital yeah you
have a funny quote by lenin that i'd
never heard of but it really did make me
laugh even if i had problems with
letting which is like uh at some point
in the 1920s you saw a slogan uh one day
you know the workers and the peasants
will rule eternally and he says this is
the problem because what we want is a
society where there will be no workers
and peasants right the whole purpose of
our enterprise is that the worker
liberates himself from being a worker or
herself
and so does the peasant right
yeah exactly like he says that uh
if if the worker and peasant rule
forever then we'll never have socialism
because socialism means the abolition of
classes
um and then this goes back to like what
i said in the very beginning which that
you know a niche on socialism would be
a fundamental negation
of of you know these fundamental aspects
of bourgeois society like wage labor and
capital and that would also include
uh the overcoming of bourgeois forms of
morality which i think would be
superseded
uh
you know increasingly superseded in a
socialist society
i'd like to ask you about one of
nietzsche's particular escapes from the
bourgeois day-to-day one of the worst
value tables the last man's value table
but but for him art and aesthetics
offers
an escape into knowledge
or into
a better form of knowledge
so where might aesthetics appear
in
nietzschean socialism um i actually have
towards the end of the book
um i have a section on aesthetics
um i've also written a short article on
uh aesthetics and marx anita
um and
you know as you mentioned
art is a very important thing for
nietzsche
uh marx is often seen as a kind of
non-aesthetic thinker
but in the 1844 manuscripts
he actually
connects human production
to aesthetics
and says that there's actually an
aesthetic
aspect to human production
he actually says that humans produce
also according to the laws of beauty
and um
i'll answer the question by going to a
distinction that
was made by kant
which is the distinction between art and
craft
and kant says that art is done for its
own sake
craft
is
not pleasurable in itself but is only
done for an external reward such as pay
so the way that we can understand
marx's idea of socialism in an aesthetic
sense is precisely as the abolition of
the distinction between art and craft
where
you know art can be useful and useful
production can be artistic i don't know
if that answers your question but um
it's this
you know it's
you know there is an idea of the
aestheticization of human life in marx
even if it's kind of you know hidden
no i i totally did not have a a correct
answer in mind i was just wondering
where you situated that considering the
fact that we're all
content creators
yeah so
yeah actually i just wanted to wrap up
uh in our traditional way sorry to be
boring but uh you've done an awful lot
over the last couple years and again uh
your new book is how to philosophize
with a hammer and sickle nietzsche marks
the 21st century uh with repeater books
uh you can find it at any number of fine
retailers uh good holiday reading if you
want to spend your time thinking about
resolutionary agitation in between
eggnog but what's next
it's an event and it's an event linked
in the description also
it will shop it um what would you say is
next for you um both in terms of
your video essays and do you think you
have another book coming uh and i guess
i will
make a pitch on behalf of victor
brzezone another member of our pill pod
who isn't here
where
you challenge uh
john rawls at various different points
in the book oh no
don't make them what do you describe it
as
uh so my my pitch for you on behalf of
uh people like myself and victor would
be uh something on uh rawls
and why it is that you think this kind
of left liberalism is bad because i'd be
interested in seeing that but anyway
have you by any chance have you read uh
philosophy and real politics by raymond
goyce i haven't no
i recommend that highly because uh
i am i'm influenced a lot by his
approach
uh where he critiques
ethics first political philosophy right
um
and he has a critique of rawls there
that i agree with and i i think uh
you're you're influenced by rawls right
yeah i mean i call myself kind of a
rosie and democratic socialist but i
completely agree that he has a
impoverished theory of power if there is
a theory of power in his work at all so
it needs to be complicated a lot with a
lot to kind of get it going
politically but i do like the kind of
account of justice in the book
um
it's pretty yeah i think you would find
that book interesting and i i love it
when raymond [ __ ] says that
the absence
of power in john ross philosophy
is not a beauty mark but a cancerous
[Laughter]
all
tumor
victor when you listen to this episode
you know uh don't be too pissed off
all right so uh i'd like to end it with
a the most general question possible
you're a content creator
in both book media uh video essay media
i have some general questions mostly
because i'm struggling with them and
we've been kind of batting them back and
forth our ideas
political if they're just opinions that
you have on the internet is the process
of a book worth it and how do you see
like the worth of making content when it
just submits into this
weird marketplace of egos and ideas and
things like that
do ideas matter there's my the sum up of
the question
well i guess my answer would be that not
not all ideas are created equal
um
and and there's no there's not really a
way to know beforehand
which ideas will become significant um
because you know that's always
throughout history has seemed kind of
almost arbitrary which ideas went out um
but
you know as marx said
philosophy
itself becomes a material force when it
grips the masses
so i think it's kind of a question of
influence
if ideas become influential enough to
make change to you know influence
changes in the way people act and what
they strive for then yeah absolutely
they do matter but then that's an
important part is that you
you try to present your ideas in a way
that they would actually have an
influence on the world
all right this has been
the pill pod uh it's matt and i
interviewing giannis chica of
cck
there's no you
cck philosophy on youtube um it looks
like you're returning to youtube how's
that been has it been better to have
these like frequent releases where you
get your little rush instead of spending
a year and a half on a book
yeah it's
i really enjoy it like i
you know some people thought i would you
know quit my youtube channel but i i
don't have any plans to do that
um
my the my favorite part
of just like
you know i guess what would be called
content creation
is
being able to see that immediate
feedback
um and looking at the comments
and
looking all at all the ways in which
my content has produced various ideas in
people and seeing discussions
you know kick-started by my video it's
it's a great feeling and it's it's nice
to have that you know at a
you know at a quicker rate and you know
that certainly would never happen at an
academic conference
the last place i'll get feedback
all right thanks so much jonas matt i
will talk to you guys soon
peace thank you
[Music]
you